that's it oh he's great I love him um so
I don't know where I said this about Joe
Rogan but I said that I get new
intimidated by him did I say that here
it's a compilation DVD I feel like
people could make one from different pop
well somebody did because so Saturday
night so this is what I've been doing
that's what I've been doing I when I go
to the comedy store and there are like
obviously there are people above me in
this pay scale and in terms of the world
of comedy I know who's below me and I
treat them accordingly okay
not mean yeah but I'm not intimidated
there are also those that I felt made it
that didn't deserve it but that's just
my opinion
and I don't I treat them accordingly but
there are those that I respect and I'm
intimidated by and Rogin and I think
Marc Maron maybe could in Bilborough
maybe although I'm very I'm friends with
all three of them okay but you know I
like to be open and say that there I
can't truly be myself I think more with
Marc now because he is well aware of
what I've been going through and he's
reached out you know he what a nice guy
but but you know so Joe was there with
his wife Saturday night he was driving
away from the store but he backs up he
sees me he gets out of his car he goes
what's up [ __ ]
where was the last time you saw him go
see some all-time yeah but I always hog
on my leave oh so I go high and he goes
so but why are you intimidated at me I
go that no I go you know I I'm not he's
like you yeah I heard you you know
somebody gave me a clip or a couple
clips and he goes I love you you know
that right I [ __ ] think you're so
funny and I love you so much and then
you know what I realized what it was
it's a Korean thing
and I'm gonna say this I think that's
what it is because in the Korean culture
your elders you have to respect them and
I have that respect for him I not only
is a great stand-up you know um but he
also you know I was associated with
Mencia back in the day because of the
video that came out because I used to
open from Mencia a lot and um you know
during that time it was very
uncomfortable with me and Rogan and that
group of guys mean a red band and
whoever might be around that circle at
the time and so I kind of built from the
ground up a relationship with them over
the [ __ ] 15 years right and now I
feel like I've gained the respect of you
know comics and whatnot anyway um but I
get you know I don't want you know I
don't want to be intrusive when I
respect somebody like that I don't want
to be intrusive because when he he shows
up comics just crowd around him right
and he plays you know and I just don't
why would I be there
you know I see hi a hug a get out right
but you know by him saying that was so
gracious it really was really gracious
he's like I want you on the show when
can you do it this and that so I'm gonna
do it and I'm now really confident about
doing it I think I know now that I can
do it I can do anything if if Ellen
DeGeneres in the park I would be
intimidated you know when I did Kate
Hudson and Oliver I'm not contaminated
it's just Rogan you know part of the
shame you know it's like Asian shame a
shame yeah